as the coronavirus doomsday models fall
apart the alarmists who pushed them are
doubling down on their draconian
policies we will examine the value of
civil disobedience when power-hungry
hypocrites get exposed and lash out then
the former Biden staff are accusing the
presumptive Democratic presidential
nominee of sexual assault files a formal
police complaint and the mainstream
media go full cover-up mode to protect
Joe and finally we take a look at the
glaring logical fallacy at the heart of
the left's favorite coronavirus
narrative all that more I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
happy Easter everybody so much to be
thankful for I know that it was a little
bit of a strange Easter and most people
were stuck indoors but that's okay you
know it's still Easter there's still so
many things to look forward to so many
bright reasons to get out of bed one of
which is our sponsors
maybe not the top reason on Easter to
get it but probably very close and I
really want to thank our sponsors right
now because obviously we're having a lot
of economic hardship some pretty
unprecedented stuff going on so for our
sponsors who are sticking around and
with us through the long haul we really
appreciate that because they allow us to
keep putting the show on the air and so
if you support them that would be really
great show them that we appreciate them
the best way to do that right now is
save everybody money with honey you know
how much I love honey honey it's just
free money okay honey is a free online
shopping tool that saves you money
online how does it work honey
automatically finds the best promo codes
and applies them to your cart I'll give
you an example the other day obviously
it's a little hard to go out physically
shopping now I wanted to order gourmet
Italian sausage on the internet so I
find the gourmet Italian sausage that I
want I throw it in my cart and then
there's no honey up there so I click on
how honey says we can save you money I
say okay it was supposed to be like $80
worth of sausage so click the little
honey button do Boop
all of a sudden I save I think was 30
bucks on my sausage 20 or 30 bucks like
that just gone I've been using honey
since before the daily wire existed
honey has found it's over 18 million
members over two billion dollars in
savings so go get it right now it's so
easy not using honey is literally
passing up free money it's free to use
and it installs in seconds plus it's
backed by PayPal so you know that it's
good get honey for free at join honey
dot-com slash Noll Skanda wles
that is join honey calm slash Knowles
it's time for civil disobedience we have
all been playing very nice with the
quarantine rules because we don't know
right we don't know if this thing is
going to wipe out all of life on Earth
or if it's being completely overblown by
the media
so everybody has urged caution we've
said everyone should take the proper
measures wash your hands social distance
all that kind of stuff right go along
with it if you can protect lives they've
gone too far it is time for civil
disobedience I know this because of
Beverly Hills Beverly Hills is
officially the place that has gone too
far
they've all been creeping toward it
Beverly Hills crossed the line
Beverly Hills just issued a mandate that
now whenever you leave your house
whenever you leave your apartment not
you're gonna go into a store not you're
gonna see people if you walk on your own
Street you need to wear a mask now
people don't have masks you can't buy
them anywhere but you have to make your
own mask put on a put on a you know
napkin or something or put on a scarf so
that you look like you're an outlaw in
an old western movie you have to do that
if you don't do that the first time a
cop stops you you'll get a warning the
second time you'll get a one thousand
dollar fine I'm not going to comply with
this I'm not going to pay the fine I
would encourage everybody else to ignore
this as well now it's not just in
Beverly Hills that's the pride I live in
Beverly Hills the problem is it's going
to be expanded this week according to
most observers it's going to be expanded
to all of LA County this could go many
other places in the country soon as well
there is no purpose to this law this is
an arbitrary power grab this directly
contradicts what these same government
people told us two weeks ago you
remember two weeks ago we were told
don't wear a masks the masks don't work
they won't prevent the spread of the
virus it you'll just look dumb if you
wear a mask the masks should only be
worn by the nurses then two weeks later
they completely reverse it they say no
masks are good now you have to wear a
mask if you don't wear a mask we're
going to charge you $1,000 no evidence
that this will prevent the spread and it
comes at the precise moment that
all of the models were proven to be
wrong and that's I think what this is
really about so mayor Garcetti of Los
Angeles he sent out this prediction two
weeks ago he said quote there is no
projection in which a couple weeks from
now we're doing fine a week or two from
now we will have images like we're
seeing in New York here in Los Angeles
see the problem with making predictions
and politics like specific predictions
with dates on them is eventually we can
go back and see if you were right or not
and it turns out Eric Garcetti mayor of
LA was completely wrong
he said two weeks ago he said there is
no projection in which LA is basically
doing fine
there's no projection in which we're not
just like New York hospitals overrun you
know epicenter of the disease that was
all wrong by the way I predicted two
weeks ago that LA would not get to that
point and I was right and Garcetti was
wrong and Garcetti said there were no
predictions but that's not true he just
didn't listen to the people who
disagreed with him and so now what does
Garcetti gonna do now that he was proven
dead wrong about this is he going to say
I'm sorry I didn't get this right never
mind I'm gonna lessen up on the
draconian policies no way that's not how
government works he's doubling down in
fact the very day it turned out that the
two weeks were up and he got it wrong he
didn't pull back on the lockdown order
he extended it so initially the lockdown
order in LA was through April 19th
now that lockdown order is through May
15th they've extended it almost another
month this is not about preventing the
spread of the virus you cannot when I go
outside if I'm just walking around
socially distanced in my neighborhood I
will not spread the virus that's it
that's not how the virus works
I'm not going to want to breathe in the
air and then that the virus is gonna
sprout wings and it's gonna fly three
miles and go into the supermarket and
see some people that's not how it works
okay so not about medical science here
this is about saving face you don't need
to take my word for it other people are
talking about it to the experts and the
courts and everybody else businesses
should reopen in Los Angeles
mayor Garcetti should be recalled he
should be thrown out of office the other
models were wrong too not just this
guy's predictions all right I could look
if Eric Garcetti were wrong about
something I wouldn't be surprised he's
one of the worst mayor's in the history
of Los Angeles which is really a it's a
real high accomplishment the national
models were wrong too how do we know
that because none other than the exalted
doctor foul she told us so on NBC News
just the other day the initial
projections which took a lot of people's
breath away was potentially a hundred to
two hundred forty thousand deaths in
this country now we have data not just
models but actual data to plug in and
and assess do you think the number of
fatalities in this country will be
significantly lower than the hundred
thousand to two hundred forty thousand
first projected okay
first of all that's not true she's seed
they're gonna change the narrative and
all of these people are just trying to
save face which she is saying here on
NBC News is that the initial projections
were that 150,000 to 200,000 people
could die in America from this virus
maybe a hundred thousand somebody
somewhere in that range the 100,000 and
200,000 those were not the initial
projections the initial projections were
over two million people remember that's
why we shut down the global economy if
the initial projections were a hundred
thousand we would have taken very
serious measures right we would have
done some social distancing we would
have made people wash their hands maybe
we would have had the masks except you
know we we keep getting contradictory
information from our government
officials the masks don't work the masks
do work people with a complete straight
face changing their tune the next day
and then throwing a thousand dollar fine
on you if you don't listen to the newest
information even though it's going to
change in two days again but the initial
it look if the initial projection had
been 100,000 we would have taken serious
precautions we would not have shut down
the global economy for it because those
numbers are not totally out of the
ordinary for other diseases that we've
seen or other social problems right over
seventy thousand people died last year
from drug overdoses we didn't shut down
the economy for it over what is it about
38,000 people die every single year
from car accidents we could easily stop
that we could easily stop that by
instituting a mandatory 25 mile an hour
speed limit mandatory everywhere it
would take a lot longer to get places
but look we'd all be able to get places
and you would save thirty-eight thousand
lives a year virtually no one would die
if we had a 25 mile an hour speed limit
why don't we do it
because as a society we're willing to
bear some risk right so nobody's
advocating for the 25 mile an hour speed
limit we would have calibrated the costs
and the risks here because guess what
when you shut down the global economy
people die a lot of people are gonna die
from this a lot of people are going to
die from suicide a lot of people are
gonna die from drug overdoses more
people than have even in the last two
years so we would have calibrated our
response the problem is the initial
projections were 2 million
don't let them forget that because
they're gonna try to Gaslight you on
this and say now we weren't talking
about 2 million yes they were so she
asked the question here's doctor fat
cheese response I do and I believe that
the mitigation I think the American
public have done a really terrific job
of just buckling down and doing those
physical separation and adhering to
those guidelines as I've told you on
this show models are really only as good
as the assumptions that you put into the
model but when you start to see real
data you could modify that model and the
real data are telling us that it is
highly likely that we're having a
definite positive effect by this
mitigation things that we're doing this
physical separation so I believe we are
gonna see a downturn in that and it
looks more like the 60,000 then the
hundreds of 200,000 but having said that
we better be careful that we don't say
okay we're doing so well we could pull
back we still have to put our foot on
the accelerator when it comes to the
mitigation and the physical separation
did you just hear what vow she said foul
she just said that he got it completely
wrong even as of a week or two ago when
he said it there would be a hundred two
hundred thousand therefore we need to do
exactly what he says I totally botched
it my numbers were totally wrong there
Fork
doing exactly what I've been saying the
whole time no I don't think so I don't
think it works that way and the other
way they're gonna Gaslight you is one
they're gonna lie to you about the
initial projections which they're
already doing and then the next thing
they're gonna do is say yes well sure we
said a week ago we said 100 to 200
thousand deaths but you know that wasn't
taking into account mitigation
strategies yes it was we were already
doing the exact same mitigation
strategies one or two weeks ago we've
been doing it for a month now all of
those models were already taking into
account all the things we're doing and
they were dead wrong we're now hearing
it's going to be less than half of what
they predicted it was going to be that's
good news we don't right we want the
total death number to be significantly
lower than we were told but we also
don't want to be lied to
because if 2 million people are gonna
die I'm willing to give up my liberties
for a brief period of time if you can
save 2 million lives if that number is
more in line with what we're seeing with
many other diseases with seasonal flus
with drug overdoses well then we've got
to calibrate our policy based on the way
that we calibrate our policy for all of
those other issues because it's not fair
and it's not reasonable to just take
this one particular plague and not
consider it against all the various
other plagues that we have to deal with
right that doesn't make a whole lot of
sense the trouble is they continue to
lie to us about this and the other way
that I know that this is we're now at
the point of saving face is that the
politicians themselves who are
instituting these policies do not
believe their own BS we'll get to the
examples of that in just a second first
I got to thank our friends over at light
stream you know now I think saving every
penny you can is particularly important
and that is especially true on your
credit card balance light streams credit
card consolidation loans have rates from
just five point nine five percent APR
with Auto pay there are absolutely no
fees you can even get your money as soon
as the day you apply which can be very
helpful these days customers have said
great things about light stream like I
heard about light stream while listening
to one of my favorite podcasts I hope
that's me and it prompted me to do some
more research after shopping around for
alone that would help me get a lower
interest rate there was no one easier to
work with plus light stream had the best
rate by far better yet no fees and I had
my cash within two business days overall
amazing experience
highly recommended apply today to get a
special interest rate discount save even
more the only way to get this discount
it's gonna light stream calm / Knowles
lig HT s TR e am dot-com / Knowles
subject to credit approval rate includes
0.50% auto pay discount terms and
conditions applying offers are subject
to change without notice
visit light stream DICOM / Knowles for
more information the politicians
themselves don't believe this BS this is
how I know that this is a naked power
grab it's probably the clearest evidence
that this is just a naked power grab the
politicians are not abiding by their
orders so from day one in New York City
where were New York finally locks down
Mayor Bill DeBlasio continued to leave
his house get in his car with his driver
go to his gym and go work out no one
else gets to go to their gym but Mayor
Bill DeBlasio he's so much more
important see all these rules they apply
to the little people the little peasants
they don't get to have their rights so
look it's they need to stay in place
shelter at home that'll prevent the
spread of the virus Bill de Blasio's
gotta work out he's gotta look good
right he's got a feel but he doesn't
feel good when he doesn't work out it's
not just bill de blasio
Chicago mayor Lori Lightfoot she's my
favorite one of them she just cut a PSA
about how you should not get a haircut
during the lockdown and that was right
before she got a haircut during the
lockdown here's the PSA Debbie getting
your roots done is not essential your
dog doesn't need to see its friends you
can work on your jump shot inside okay
yep very simple PSA come on I'm the
voice of reason here you don't need to
go out you don't you don't need to get
your roots done alright that's
not essential so it became very awkward
when Chicago Mayor Lori Lightfoot went
out and got her roots done when she went
out and got a haircut she was called out
for this at a press conference the
arrogance the condescension the sheer
pride in her response tells you
everything you need to know about this
power grab I'm out in the public eye and
you know I'm a I'm I'm a person who I
take my personal hygiene very seriously
as I said I felt like I needed to have a
haircut I'm not able to do that myself
and so I got a haircut she's very
different from you you see you are a
filthy mongrel but she takes her hygiene
very seriously
you basically just roll around and slop
in filth all day would you that's fine
for you you're a little person you don't
even go on television okay Laurie she's
got to go on TV all right she's in the
public eye and she unlike you takes her
hygiene seriously the fact that she
could say this with a straight face the
fact that Bill DeBlasio could do this he
goes that one day says you got to lock
at home but then I'm gonna go to my gym
and he sees no contradiction here tells
you that this lockdown is now all about
power
I was totally willing to abide this
thing for a while when we didn't know
when the models were projecting doomsday
but then doctor foul she said the models
are only as good as the data you put
into them but the data now are coming in
the hard data and it turns out that the
models were totally wrong now they're
being exposed now these people who are
putting one set of draconian rules for
you and then living by a completely
different set of rules they are being
exposed for what this has become you
would expect when the data shows
something new that these politicians
would change course but they're not the
only way they're changing course is
they're doubling down because this is
about a an arbitrary power grab that is
precisely the time for civil
disobedience
beyond the orders that are merely stupid
I'm thinking of face masks for walks
around the neighborhood when you're
separated from anybody you know within I
I or earshot some orders are worse
some orders are downright illegal or
unconstitutional an example of this we
saw over the weekend for Easter you know
you can't go to church right now I
really like going to church I think
America was founded on religious liberty
I think the pilgrims came over here to
practice their religion America has
always been a more religious country
than virtually anywhere else in the
world certainly anywhere else in the
West
okay so religion really matters and yet
I understand that if there's a very
dangerous play going on that's gonna
kill two million people you got to maybe
close the churches totally get that
churches have responded
one such response was a church decided
to do a drive-up service you know you go
to a drive-in movie theater 50 years ago
well you can go to a drive-in Church
same great solution right because it's
just your immediate household in the car
you're not touching anybody you're not
talking to anybody
well the Democratic mayor of Louisville
Kentucky decided to ban that - what
possible effect on the public health
could that have none whatsoever but it's
an arbitrary power grab for this jerk
who probably doesn't care very much for
religion so he bans this thing and do
people say peep do they do they protest
do they know okay and that was the time
to do it it would be one thing if these
laws were being applied evenly if they
were being applied fairly but they're
not around the country almost everywhere
in the country certain states had been
smarter about this but almost everywhere
churches are being hit especially hard
the police are being deployed to
churches meanwhile head shops are
remaining open abortion mills are
remaining open you in Los Angeles
marijuana dispensaries are an essential
service for many people in Los Angeles
it probably is an essential service but
churches are shut down the cops are
going to show up if you open your church
so you can go by that sticky
he cush you can go kill your baby those
are both essential services but you
can't worship God on Easter doesn't make
a lot of sense to me because if I'm
going into the head shop or if I'm going
into an abortion clinic I'm going to
interact with a lot more people right
there's a lot less social distance in
both of those places and generally
potheads are not known for keeping their
social distance all right but they're
you're gonna talk to people you're gonna
you're gonna interact with people if you
go to drive in church you're not going
to touch anybody these laws are not
being applied fairly at all the liberal
places and look I understand a lot of
conservatives occasionally like to smoke
the devil's lettuce all right I'm not
making any point about that right now
I'm just saying generally it's the left
that supports these places they get a
pass and the churches get shuttered
other places this is happening to de
Blasio in New York threatened if a
church were to open up or a synagogue
were to open up he threatened to
permanently shut them down not that he
was going to go in and say okay for the
rest of the quarantine you're out you're
done not even though he was gonna arrest
the pastor for churches and synagogues
he was going to permanently close down
the buildings those are the only two
religions by the way that he mentioned a
couple other faith groups went
unmentioned they're apparently allowed
to do whatever they want bill de blasio
is a little more afraid of them but
churches and synagogues shut down in
Kentucky the Democratic governor Andy
Beshear announced that he would send the
police to churches to record the license
plates of anyone who attended and then
have the cops show up at their door and
forced them into quarantine for 14 days
when the cops are prowling around your
church's recording your license plates
that's the time for civil disobedience
this is obviously BS but it's also quite
arguably illegal and/or unconstitutional
and people should resist it and by the
way not just my opinion this is not
merely the opinion of some guy on the
internet this
also the opinion of federal courts and
apparently the Attorney General of the
United States so at least in Louisville
we had a court weigh in on this in
Louisville a federal judge ruled on
Saturday so right before Easter that the
drive-through church was right about
their religious liberties being violated
and they permitted that establishment to
hold the drive-up service so because the
church pushed back fought against this
said wait a second I know that the local
authorities have police power especially
in times of plague but they this is not
fair this is not being applied evenly
they fought it in court and they won how
about on the national level the
spokesman for Bill Barr the Attorney
General just tweeted out this line quote
during the sacred week for many
Americans AG bar is monitoring
government regulation of religious
services while social distancing
policies are appropriate during this
emergency they must be applied
even-handedly and not single out
religious organizations expect action
from the DOJ next week exclamation point
great news because here's the thing I'm
not suggesting radicalism on this
quarantine issue I'm not saying that it
is necessarily wrong to have lockdowns
or quarantine s or to protect the public
health I'm saying that the laws have to
be applied evenly and fairly that they
can't be arbitrary power grabs that they
can't be ways for failed politicians to
try to save face after they've already
violated so many of our heretofore
cherished rights okay and by the way
enforcement of these lockdowns is not
just an academic matter okay it's not
just something that we kick around the
water cooler and and that we have
academic debates about the enforcement
of these lockdowns is increasingly
becoming violent we'll get some evidence
of that in just a moment best example
and that is Philly then we'll get to the
Joe Biden assault because finally the
mainstream media have sort of broken
their silence about the Joe Biden
assault allegation but like sort of and
not really and it's really really sad
for them we will get to all of that and
so much more
first though I've got to thank you I've
got a thing
you for being daily wire members if
you're not a member now is the time to
do it we have an excellent deal when you
become a daily wire insider plus or
all-access member what do you get you'll
get well you'll get the leftist here's
tumbler that's pretty good
do you know what else you'll get you
will get another leftist here's tumblr
you will get two magnificent leftist
here's tumblers that is by my
calculation twice as good look I'm not
one of these geniuses who makes all the
models and everything all right I'm no
I'm no doctor foul G but I think that
two is twice as good as one that's right
one for you one for corn pop for our
existing members look I know many of you
are gonna feel a little envious right
now but don't worry we have a special
offer coming up just for you as well the
only wire members get many amazing
benefits including of course the
magnificent irreplaceable leftist tears
tumblr you also get an ad-free website
experience access to our live broadcast
the show library you get everything ok
you get everything go to daily wire.com
slash subscribe to get started and get
10% off with promo code Noel's Kenna
wles that's daily wire.com slash
subscribe coupon code Knowles we'll be
right back with a whole lot more
the enforcement of the lockdowns is
becoming violent best example of this is
in philly so you remember it in philly
at the start of this lockdown philly
decided they were gonna stop arresting
criminals not all criminals but the
low-level criminals and i'm not just
talking about you steal a candy bar at a
store I'm talking about burglary
vandalism pimping dealing narcotics
you know offenses that are low level
compared to murder but they're you know
they're serious offenses to the
Philadelphia Police said we're not going
to arrest people for that the cop could
watch you committing the act will not
arrest you for it this was all in order
to thin out the jail population
ostensibly so the corona virus doesn't
spread so in Philly if you commit a
crime you're probably not going to go to
jail if you're in jail by the way you
might get out of jail early because they
want to reduce the jail population but
if you don't comply with the facemask
order guess what happens you will get
manhandled by the cops here is a Philly
official telling a bus rider that very
fact you have to get off the bus you
have to get off the bus
sir
sir sir sir you got to get off the bus
you think it ends there no it doesn't
here's the next video that we saw of
multiple cops I assume cops or at least
transit officials dragging this guy off
the bus by his legs
take a listen he's got one leg outside
the bus right now he's holding out of
the rail with the other one
Wow that's that scene is pretty amazing
not to bring race into this but the left
would always bring race into this when
it comes to interactions between black
civilians and white police officers
except for right now what happened to
black lives matter what happened to no
stop and frisk what happened to all that
goes out the window you got a bunch of
mostly white cops pulling a black man
off a city bus dragging him by his legs
because he doesn't have a facial mask on
the left is dead silent on it for me I
don't think the racial angle matters at
all here I think the fact that anybody
is being manhandled by the cops when
they could just hand him a mask
give him the mat you can't get the damn
masks anywhere okay cops you got a mask
handed to him
I'll comply that's fine if if you're in
a city you're on a public transportation
you're in very close proximity to people
now the experts are telling us that
masks help in that case fine I'll be a
sport give me the mask that would be a
whole lot easier than ripping this guy
off of the bus but doesn't matter
because this is about flexing muscles
this is about the government showing you
how little freedom you actually have how
much power they can have doesn't matter
if it's legal who's gonna stop them
who's gonna stop them enough is enough
enough is too much
we gave the alarmists the benefit of the
doubt I don't even really regret that
better safe than sorry right so we give
the alarmists the benefit of the doubt
they were completely wrong
okay fair enough
now they want to double down because
they're humiliated that they got it
completely wrong there's some people on
the right to mostly the left but some
people on the right - they were wrong
totally wrong it's time to start
reopening president Trump wants to
reopen that's the story at least that's
what we're being told by The Washington
Post so take it with a grain of salt but
still that's the reporting we're getting
behind closed doors
president Trump concerned with the
sagging economy has sought a strategy
for resuming business activity by May
first according to people familiar with
the discussions very possible this is
being floated by the Trump White House
it's being leaked to the wopo to see
what the reaction is well you and I and
everybody else should give the Trump
White House encouragement that's a great
idea open this damn thing up by May 1st
if there were any evidence that any of
what the alarmists were saying was true
perhaps we could still urge caution
perhaps not because there's a lot of
cost to the remaining shutdown economic
cost obviously we're you know we're just
completely destroying the global economy
but human human life costs - people are
gonna die every day that this drags on
more people will die from this open it
back up there's a political cost - by
the way the longer President Trump keeps
this shutdown the tougher it's gonna be
for him to win in November and that's
another reason why these Democratic
politicians and the mainstream media but
I repeat myself are doing everything in
their power to keep this country shut
down a part of that is they don't have a
candidate to go up against Trump in
November they've got the walking cadaver
formerly known as Joe Biden he's the
candidate okay yeah you think he's I
think you could probably get to 50%
unemployment Trump would still have a
good shot of beating Joe Biden who wants
to vote for that guy very few people and
now he's got a problem he's got a me-too
problem you know what's so amazing
nobody's talked about this I think
Jeremy boring is the the first guy I've
heard mentioned this the left made such
a big hullabaloo in in 2016 because
President Trump once joked on a hot mic
with Billy Bush and said that he's a
Hollywood star so women let him grab
them by the you know we're right he said
oh look when you're a famous when you're
a Hollywood star they let you grab them
by the you know where Joe Biden
is currently being accused of actually
grabbing a woman by the you know we're
not joking about it on the access
hollywood bus but actually doing it and
they don't and they kill trump for it
and they don't even freaking mention it
when joe biden does it well they're
gonna have to mention it now because the
woman who's accusing him of this is
filing a formal police complaint she did
that late thursday afternoon she filed a
report of the incident with the sexual
assault unit of washington DC
Metropolitan Police Department as of
Friday the day after that guess how many
stories the mainstream media had run on
this allegation against Joe Biden
Washington Post take a guess zero New
York Times take a guess you got zero CNN
take a guess
zero MSNBC take a guess zero none nada
nope
Yente there guess how many accusations
or we guess how many well I guess they
were accusations because how many
stories the mainstream media ran against
Brett Kavanaugh talking about the
allegations against him which by the way
were much much weaker than the
allegations against Joe Biden the
allegations against Cavanaugh remember
the people who were at the alleged party
didn't remember any of the facts the
girl the woman Christine Blasi Ford
changed her story
multiple times there's no evidence that
many of these people even met one
another than the other allegations were
just completely discredited by a guy
who's currently in the can Michael
avenatti you remember that those were
totally frivolous the media ran all
these stories about them this is a Joe
Biden staffer this woman actually worked
for the guy I still don't think they're
particularly credible but you know
they're way more credible than the ones
against Kavanagh guess how many stories
the mainstream media ran against
Cavanaugh New York Times over 90
Washington Post over a hundred CNN over
a hundred MSNBC over 100 and they can't
be bothered to write one article about a
far more credible allegation against
Biden New York Times finally runs the
story
they finally run the story they can't
even do it honestly here's that here's
the headline examining Tara Reid's
sexual assault allegation against Joe
Biden
you can see here in the first the first
page or so this is just defending Joe
Biden and defending themselves I love
this this is by the third fourth fifth
paragraph soon after Ms Reid made the
new allegation in a podcast interview
released on March 25th
The Times began reporting on her account
and seeking corroboration through
interviews documents and sources BS they
didn't run anything they didn't run one
article about it now they're trying to
fudge the language here right so they're
gonna say well we began reporting we
didn't publish anything but you know we
like picked up the phone we called some
people we tried to try to disprove this
as long as we could for several weeks
and then three weeks later we finally
decided to write a word about it in
mostly defending Joe Biden
so they defend themselves they defend
Joe Biden he says last year mr. Biden 77
acknowledged the women's complaints
about his conduct saying his intentions
were benign and promising to be quote
more mindful and respectful of people's
personal space and even in this defense
of them they were devious they were
deceitful so initially initially here is
what the New York Times article
initially read no other allegation about
sexual assault surfaced in the course of
reporting nor did any former Biden staff
members corroborate any details of MS
Reid's allegation
The Times found no pattern of sexual
misconduct by mr. Biden beyond the hugs
kisses and touching that women
previously said made them uncomfortable
okay now we all know about that we know
numerous complaints against Joe Biden by
women who you know he kissed them on the
cheek or something and they didn't like
this they stealth edit that paragraph
they don't put a correction they don't
say they additive it they just stealth
at it of it the paragraph now reads no
other allegation about sexual assault
surfaced in the course of reporting nor
did any former Biden staff members
corroborate any details of miss Reed's
allegation
The Times found no pattern of sexual
misconduct by mr. Biden notice anything
missing I'm
sure the Biden campaign went in and
rewrote this article that's the sort of
hackery that the New York Times is
descended into okay then they go on they
and then they finally on the second page
second or third page they they say
here's ms reads account and it reads
like a police report they don't they
don't put any sort of emotion into it
and then they give her account but the
point is clear they don't believe her
they know that Biden is a terrible
candidate that's why they're doing this
they know that President Trump has
handled coronavirus very well and so
they're doing anything they can to
resuscitate Joe Biden both as a matter
of his reputation and probably
physically trying to resuscitate him so
he can go out on the campaign trail
they're also trying one last-ditch
effort to make the coronavirus trumps
fault so here is here is something that
yeah this bid this is by the way much
longer article than the article about
the sexual assault allegation against
Joe Biden this is called he should have
seen what was coming behind Trump's
failure on the virus an examination
reveals the president was warned about
the potential for a pandemic but that
internal divisions lack of planning and
his faith in his own instincts led to a
halting response okay here we go what do
we got so we got a full-page of how
Trump is the devil and you know it's all
his fault
and we got another page of yet Trump is
a really horrible guy and it was all his
fault and you know something's missing
from this coverage of how the pandemic
took over the United States and you had
a whole other page the third page of
that oh yeah there at the very bottom
China you know China which caused the
entire pandemic China which developed it
somehow probably naturally but I guess
it could have been in a lab - the thing
develops in China then China completely
covers it up and and punishes
journalists who talk about it and
punishes whistleblowers who talk about
it covers it up to the point that the
University of Southampton said if they
had stopped covering it up three weeks
earlier would have reduced spread by 95
percent even if they had stepped one
week earlier would have reduced spread
by 66 percent they covered it up for
months and months and months bottom of
the third page beginning of the fourth
page that's where you see China
mentioned in this article now it's so
flimsy right it doesn't land these
attacks that Trump is not taking
coronavirus serious
one it doesn't land because their BS
alarmist predictions that they tried to
sell us for two weeks the two million
dead number haven't happened two million
dead now it's going to be 60,000 dead
60,000 dead something to take very
seriously but it's not not 2 million ok
so that's part of the reason why it
doesn't land the other reason it doesn't
land is because the liberal governors of
the most liberal states in the country
or saying that President Trump is doing
a good job here's Andy Cuomo in New York
I've worked very hard with the President
of the United States we've had our
political differences in the past no
doubt but there's also no doubt that
I've worked hand in glove with the
president here and he has been
responsive to New York and responsive to
New York's needs and he's done it
quickly and he's done it efficiently
I've literally had conversations with
him in the morning where he turned
around a decision by that afternoon I've
been in the federal government they know
what it's like to make a decision and he
has really responded to New York's needs
so keep politics out of it focus on
government and focus on policy that's a
ringing endorsement I get it Andy Cuomo
wants to play nice with the president
right now the president has said nice
things about Andy Cuomo they're working
together this does happen during times
of crisis but Cuomo didn't need to be
that effusive okay he could have
tempered his remarks he could have made
shorter remarks and he didn't because
Trump's doing a good job and the
governor's know it it's not just and
equal moe saying that you know Trump and
Cuomo have known each other for a long
time they're both New Yorkers and Andy
Cohen was father was the former governor
a kind of legendary governor of New York
they've known each other a long time
same thing is true on the other side of
the country though in California Gavin
Newsom liberal liberal governor of
California saying the same thing that
Trump has done a great job you know
obviously you've had differences with
the president in the past tough words on
on both sides you've been able to work
together it seems in this for the needs
of your state yeah look I mean I said
we're involved in 68 lawsuits with the
Trump administration I've been on your
so I haven't been timid he certainly
hasn't been too
but I got to say this it's just the fact
I'd be lying to you I'd be lying to the
American people every single direct
request that he was capable of meeting
he has met we have the USNS mercy in
California because of his direct
intervention and support 2,000 of these
federal medical stations because of his
direct support and so I can only speak
for myself but I have to be
complimentary otherwise I would be
simply lying to you misleading you and
that is a wonderful thing to be able to
say and I hope that continues but this
has been a remarkable moment or at least
we've been able to arise above that
partisanship I actually really like the
way that Newsom puts it here because he
puts it in kind of honest political
terms he goes look basically what you're
saying is I understand Anderson I
understand CNN that you want me to
criticize Trump but I can't do it I wish
I could I'm sorry I know I'm letting you
down that I can't criticize Trump but I
would be lying it would be so clearly
dishonest if I said the Trump's not
doing a good job because he is doctor
foul Qi said earlier in the show he said
that the models are only as good as the
data you put into them right so we have
the fake data the data given to us by
the mainstream media the data given to
us by many Democratic politicians early
on okay that led to a certain response
that led to a certain picture of the
virus a certain picture of the political
situation those data were wrong now we
have new data okay and the new data on
the number of sick the number of
hospitalized in the revenger baited the
number of dead new data on the federal
government's response we have new data
so we got to look at what those new data
show us and the new data show us things
are very much in the right direction
that the alarmists were wrong and it's
time to start listening to the people
who were right and stop listening to the
people who were wrong and speaking of
right stop giving away all of our rights
to failed politicians who were simply
trying to save face because they bungled
this so bad
two power-hungry hypocrites who don't
care that the data have changed they're
sticking with their old story we should
not allow them to do that before we
there's just one thing I want to get to
there is this one logical fallacy that
the left keeps coming back to when
they're trying to explain the
coronavirus and the argument is this we
are the virus the reason that there is
this corona virus is it's the Earth's
natural response to how the human beings
are damaging the environment and so the
earth is just there so put upon that the
earth is just you know focus really hard
and created this virus to teach us all a
lesson and is it important that we teach
that that we learn that lesson
and we stop attacking the earth Spike
Lee the very overrated filmmaker is
saying this Spike Lee just said quote
you know why the reason I read an
article about it how pollution is
clearing up skies are clear animals are
coming out I mean you know the earth was
angry at us people may think I'm crazy
that I believe it in my heart and soul
that we had gone too far and Earth said
hold up we got to change this we're
killing this planet and this time that
everything was shut down the earth has
come alive
Spike Lee the actor Idris Elba said
almost exactly the same thing has been
taking a kick in
you know we've damaged our world and you
know it's no surprise that our world is
reacting to the human race there's no
surprise that a virus has been created
that is going to slow us down and
ultimately make us think differently
about our world and ourselves that's
like a real for me
that's a stand out thing that's very
obvious that this is almost like the
world's cry out to like hey hey hey they
kicking me you know what you're doing is
not good so I'll get rid of you as any
any any organism would do is try and get
rid of an infection and maybe this is
the wildstar that's got to be it right
it's not just Spike Lee it's not just
address el but even Pope Francis came
out and apparently said this there is an
expression in Spanish God always
forgives we forgive sometimes but nature
never forgives who now speaks of the
fires in Australia or remembers that 18
months ago a boat could cross the North
Pole be as the glaciers had all melted
who
speaks now of the floods I don't know if
these are the Revenge of nature but they
are certainly nature's responses now I
am going to just assume as a Catholic
I'm just going to assume that the Pope
was mistranslated okay let's go with
that is there evidence I don't know I
haven't I'm not gonna look into it I
don't going to assume that the Pope was
mistranslated it's a good data point to
have but let's focus on address Elba and
Spike Lee and the other people saying
this this is a very dumb point it is
there is actually a name for this
logical fallacy this is called the
pathetic fallacy the pathetic fallacy is
when you attribute human feelings and
human responses to inanimate objects and
we do this all the time and especially
the left does this all the time because
especially the secular Left does this
constantly the reason they do that is
because it tends to be the case that
your religious people are the most
superstitious of all so they have the
crystals and stuff and the the mantras
and the yoga and all that kind of stuff
but a parent you know who knows what the
Pope said also it's the pathetic fallacy
and it's simply not true the rock
doesn't have feelings the earth is not
an organism it's a rock it doesn't feel
anything you can take a sledgehammer
just are beating the earth you can take
a knife and turn a switchblade just stab
the earth take your gun out shoot round
after round into the earth the earth
will not hurt okay it won't bleed it
won't feel bad it's a rock
human beings have human feelings and
human thoughts and human will and human
action the reason we have a pandemic is
not because the earth is really upset
that we're fracking or something or
driving SUVs the reason we have a
pandemic is because the human beings in
the Chinese government covered up their
local epidemic did it escaped from a lab
possibly was it just because someone ate
a bad case of bat soup could be that too
even though that storyline is kind of
falling apart right now but let's say
that's the case this is human action
that is causing it and we all want to
kumbaya and pretend that nobody's ever
at fault for anything
some people are at fault okay the
Chinese government is at fault they
caused this some people in the media
some people on the professional left
scared everybody to death based on BS
some politicians tried to grab power
some hypocrites wouldn't have abide by
their own draconian rules but now
they're trying to double down on them
right now
that ain't the earth those are human
beings causing those problems and we
need to hold those human beings
accountable but we'll have to put that
off until tomorrow because that is our
show in the meantime I'm Michael Knowles
this is the Michael Nolt show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director hovel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer Danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson hair and makeup nikka Geneva
production assistant
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune in to the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there